joe biden is banning seven countries
worth of africans from entering the
country as the new omicron variant of
kovid rages across the continent
the president has cut off travel from
south africa botswana zimbabwe namibia
lizoto ezwitini
that's actually what i had for dinner
last night mozambique in malawi which
might remind some people who can
remember all the way back to last year
of donald trump's travel ban which joe
biden called quote hysterical xenophobia
here is how white house press secretary
jensaki tried to explain away the change
of tune
before joe biden was president he said
that coveted travel restrictions on
foreign countries were hysterical
xenophobia and fear-mongering so what
changed
well i would say first to put it in full
context peter what the president was
critical of was the way that the former
president put out i believe a xenophobic
tweet uh
and how he called that what he called
the cocoronovirus uh and and who he
directed it at the president has not
been critical of
travel restrictions we have put those in
place ourselves we put them in place
ourselves in the spring but no he does
not believe he believes we should follow
the advice of health and medical experts
that's exactly what he did and putting
in place these restrictions over the
weekend
ah okay you see it wasn't what trump did
but how he did it
the white house is now resorting to the
retort your wife makes after a pointless
argument it's not what you said it's how
you said it so biden bans
africans because of the omicron just one
more variant just a few more days to
slow the spread we're now we're now at
20 months of 15 days to slow the spread
but just a little bit more
and then don't worry you can get back to
your normal life people obviously are
looking at the hypocrisy they're looking
at what seemed to be these pointless
lockdowns this unnecessary up ending of
our way of life and they're saying cut
it out we don't want this anymore we
don't want the lockdowns we don't want
the masks we don't want the mandatory
fauciachi we don't want you we don't
want you ruling class that's why
your approval ratings are all
in the doldrums right now one of the
worst parts about staring at a screen
all day is that usually you get a ton of
blue light in your eyes and you don't
even really notice it you don't notice
it until you block out the blue light
and then your eyes feel a little less
strained and it can it can help with
anxiety and headaches and all that sort
of stuff this is why i love
the blue blocks blue light computer
glasses
other brands do not compare to the
quality you get from blue blocks classes
blue blocks are made in optics
laboratories in australia they are not
mass produced in factories in asia and
unlike other blue light glass companies
blue blocks uses science-backed
technology tested to ensure that they
work these classes come in
non-prescription prescription and
reading options blue blocks also has
great products such as the low blue
light bulbs red light therapy devices
and 100 blackout sleep masks all backed
by
science blue blocks ship worldwide in
rapid time they have easy returns and
exchanges
trust me you're going to love it when
you block out that blue light blue
blocks currently has their black friday
sale campaign running great news for all
of you is you can save 25 off all
products through the end of the day
today the 30th of november 2021
i definitely recommend ordering more
products during this mega sale this is
right now it's i know we're going an
extra day but go check it out
blueblox.com to save 25
blueblocks.com blublox.com
25 discount code is automatically
applied at checkout glad you like that
clip hold up
ring that bell
ring it
ring it then you'll get the
notifications and actually sometimes you
won't get the notifications because our
dear friends at big tech don't always
love to give our subscribers the
notifications that's why you got to go
over to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play subscribe to the michael
knowles show m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s
s-h-o-w subscribe leave a five-star
review we'll see
[Music]
[Music]
you